we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in oh
hi David so Karl kolinsky recently found
us so that tax cuts for the rich add to
the deficit right can you explain to me
that I'm a bit ignorant on my topic you
should split them in why tax cuts for
the rich add the deficit doesn't really
make much sense to me yeah okay so
listen this is someone who calls all the
time and they it's never clear whether
they're being sort of honest in their
questions or whether they're trying to
troll but it doesn't matter it's a good
question right okay so Kyle kolinsky I
many others the Congressional Budget
Office right lot a lot of agencies and
people have said tax cuts for the rich
add to the deficit why is that the math
of it is pretty simple the deficit is
government revenues minus expenditures
when expenditures are bigger than
revenues you have a deficit when
revenues are bigger than expenditures
you have a surplus so why would tax cuts
for the rich grow the deficit it's quite
simple any kind of tax cut is a decrease
in revenue for the government okay so we
have it's a very simple equation revenue
minus expenditures if you cut taxes for
the rich revenue goes down so that is
going to increase the deficit to counter
that you would need to demonstrate that
by cutting taxes for the rich you will
grow revenues or decrease deficit or
decrease spending in such a way that
would make up for the lost government
revenue it just doesn't happen right I
mean we know that cutting taxes for the
rich is not economically stimulative
cutting taxes for people who need every
dollar lower lower middle class middle
class that is economically stimulative
because the people that get that extra
money are going to spend it and can
actually create more tax revenue through
the employment that exists because of
the demand for products and services
from those lower lower middle and middle
class people so the math is is really
amazingly simple and you can you don't
have to take my word for it and in fact
I would encourage you not to
research whether tax cuts for the rich
are economically stimulative or not and
I'm not talking about research it on you
know Breitbart I'm talking about read
the actual academic literature about it
and also just run the numbers right I
mean imagine we ran through the numbers
a last week or the week before imagine a
ten thousand dollar economy with a forty
percent tax rate right which brings in
four thousand dollars in tax revenues
ten thousand dollar economy four
thousand and tax rates in taxes when
forty percent is the tax revenue if you
cut the tax rate to thirty percent now
the government has lost a thousand
dollars in revenue in order to make up
for that in order for the tax cut to be
deficit-neutral
the thousand dollars has to be made up
as revenue on new income if you cut
taxes for the rich that's not going to
generate another thousand dollars in
government revenue I mean it's it's
funny because the numbers are actually
so simple that some people hear them and
they say there must be a more
complicated explanation that can't
possibly be right but it's right that's
just the way it is and I encourage you
to fact check me research it on the
bonus show today
one of the Las Vegas shooters brothers
has been arrested on suspicion of
possessing child pornography we will
talk about that New Zealand is taking
big league action against foreign home
buyers we've talked about the issues of
the real estate bubble and price
increases in some markets in the United
States we've talked about what Vancouver
Canada has decided to do to try to stop
foreign real estate buyers from driving
prices up and making it more difficult
for locals to a horde afford housing New
Zealand is banning foreign homebuyers
altogether we will talk about that and
lastly we know that Trump has cut
funding for our national parks fees to
enter some of our most popular national
parks would be doubled or in some cases
increase even more
under a new Interior Department plan and
I have to tell you for different reasons
I have mixed feelings about this and we
will talk about that and more on the
bonus show how do you get the
world-famous bonus show there are two
ways number
one you go to david pakman.com slash
membership and you sign up for a
membership you'll get instant access to
the bonus show it is a whole extra show
that we do every day for our members you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 if you want a 40% discount
off of membership that's one way to get
access to the bonus show the second way
to get access to the bonus show is by
becoming a $5 a month patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
get access to the same bonus show
membership and patreon gives you access
to the same commercial free video feed
of the show it's just a matter of what
you prefer patreon or membership sign up
we will talk to you on the bonus show in
mere minutes if you're not a member
we'll talk to you tomorrow on the Friday
show